I am my name is Daniel Cooney I've  traveled from Sydney Australia for this  course today and over the last six  months I've been interacting with Samuel  and I must say that this trip that I  booked was purely to come to this event  and I would highly recommend anyone in  the UK if you're interested in any  property or especially HMO that Samuel  is is an absolute legend and he  explained everything very succinctly the  day's been amazing it's been filled with  interactive activities and I just you  know I like the way he delivers it's  full of energy and and if you want to  know about property in York and HMOs get  to this corset sure